apple is bringing back a legendary
product that changed the whole
world i know some of you teens and young
adults don't even know about this but
today we will take a step back in time
and see how steve jobs shocked everybody
and everybody was on this new tech we'll
talk about what it is when it's going to
come out and how it is going to be
affecting the new m2 max let's go ahead
and jump right back in time back in 1999
steve jobs went on stage and showed off
the ibook g3 this was a colorful laptop
it looks really funky and weird today
but looked really awesome back then go
ahead and let me know down below if
you're somebody that has used one of
these macbooks now not only did it have
unique features like a built-in handle
to make it much easier to carry it also
had one secret feature that we'll talk
about in a sec it also had pretty good
performance especially for the price tag
where apple priced it lower than the
competitors while offering a lot more
bang for the buck that kind of sounds
like the m1 macbook air to me right now
where it's cheaper and better than all
of the competition in that category
after steve gave all of the specs and
then showed off different versions of
television ads that they would do back
in the day he came out with his
legendary well but there is one more
thing
there is one more thing let me just show
this to you for a minute okay okay come
on up here i just want to show you this
working he brought a cameraman on stage
and proceeded to open up the laptop and
he connected to the internet which was
completely normal but then he busted out
the hula hoop and the crowd went
nuts so what did he do with them
well he spun it through and all around
the laptop while being connected to the
internet something that was never done
before
yes apple was the very first company to
release a laptop with wireless
networking most of us our age my age and
younger didn't even know this and in the
following years they changed the world
with this new laptop and this new
networking that they were including
everybody from teachers students people
at home were switching to wi-fi and
enjoying the freedom that it gave now in
order to make this possible they needed
networking a wi-fi router to allow
people to connect to and to make it easy
which is where this flying saucer comes
in now apple wasn't the first company to
make a wi-fi router but they were the
ones that really pushed this whole
technology forward the airport base
station looked funky but it gave you
everything you need with the modem
inside connectivity with a bunch of
devices good range very easy to use and
it actually had the fastest speed that
just came out for wireless connectivity
it was 10 times faster than before so if
apple made the first laptop with wi-fi
and they really revolutionized this
whole industry what's happening today
well four years ago apple officially
discontinued their lineup of airport
extreme and time capsules which i'll
talk about in a sec and they just dump
this whole market we're gonna talk about
why they did that why it's coming back
and how we know and how it's gonna
affect these brand new macs coming out
what changes those are going to bring
this info that we have is coming from
imagine boo and if you're wondering well
who the heck is that this is a guy that
covers a lot of information leaks a lot
of software stuff that we've actually
covered in the past and if you don't
think he's credible check this out he
was actually the first person to talk
about mixer software that apple is
developing to bring a mac os like
experience to the ipads that we covered
now this came out we were hoping that it
is true and then just a little bit later
patents were released and approved
showing this whole interface how you'll
be able to connect your ipad to a
keyboard and get a mac os like
experience so apple's patents backed up
what he was talking about in terms of
software now on top of that steve trott
and smith just put out this information
talking about webkit and how it just had
extra infrastructure added to allow for
a multi-tasking mode on ios that looks
like it's a system toggle that enables
freely resizable windows now we know
wwdc is coming out we are going to get
ipad os 16. this phone info is coming up
and they are actually making
preparations for it as we see so here it
is the new hardware the new leaked
information for majin buu and according
to his sources they are seeing from mac
os 13 that there should be a version of
time machine the backup system for your
max that's completely redone it's going
to be integrated with icloud drive and
in addition apple is expecting to
introduce new airports in november why
would apple want to do that why would
they discontinue their airports four
years ago and then now all of a sudden
they're gonna be bringing it back well
when we take a look back at the airports
they were launching them when we had
major changes in technology the first
flying saucer model brought this
technology to the masses and then the
airport extreme is what allowed for
ultra fast speeds and for broadband to
be able to use instead of slow dial up
on top of that they made it so easy to
set up and to use instead of having to
use a web login browser that's a lot of
them still need now and then four to
five years later we had another
breakthrough product called time capsule
this took your airport extreme and your
hard drive that you would use for backup
and fuse them together this gave people
a super easy and reliable solution that
was automated and worked on multiple
macs in your house without having to do
anything it was incredible and then
another four years later apple brought
out the latest airport extreme design
with the trashcan mac pro that came out
right as we got the ac standard that had
multiple streams dual band boarding
antennas super great range and it also
could include a hard drive for that time
capsule backup so this design was their
very last one that they didn't update
for a while and then they ended up
canceling now believe it or not people
are still spending a lot of money on
this older outdated deck because it's
easy to use it's reliable and you have
those backups so why did apple not
really change anything well not much
happened in many years after that the
wireless stayed the same the speeds many
routers are still using those today and
third-party options got so cheap that
these were just kind of too expensive
for a lot of people and in fact even the
2019 mac pro and all of the macs other
than the new m1s only support internet
speeds as fast as this airport extreme
they don't support wi-fi six now
recently wi-fi six started to come out
the new macbooks finally support it but
they're still a little bit back dated on
the bluetooth and we now have wi-fi 6e
that was released and people start to
spend way more money on their routers
some of these wi-fi 60 routers are
incredibly expensive and people are
buying them hard drives have also gotten
much cheaper since apple came out with a
time capsule and were charging a ton of
money for this new technology and with
that not only has it been four years
since apple discontinued the airport
line but they are also going to be
coming out with a new mac pro that they
talked about which is right in time for
new technology wi-fi 6e and an airport
extreme or whatever they want to call it
that also enables that technology bring
me to these new macs if apple is going
to put out a new wi-fi router just like
we've seen before every time they
released a new one it was the very
newest latest and greatest wi-fi
technology going back all the way to the
very first one this is going to be prime
time to switch to this new generation
upgrade all their connectivity and gives
users you know what they want now along
with that leak we also have the info
about icloud drive you've been able to
back up your ipads your iphones your
apple watch all to icloud drive but on
the mac side it has only been certain
files that if they're deleted online or
on your mac they get removed you know
vice versa so if you have been using
that it doesn't work great you still
have to use time machine and because of
that people are still buying these very
expensive overpriced old time capsule
airport extremes to have automatic
backups that are off of their laptop
without having to plug in a cable i'm
really shocked that apple has not
implemented this yet with icloud drive
now if they're going to be doing this
maybe they won't put a hard drive in the
actual airport extreme maybe they're
going to wrap it up in their bundles
and with that they might also enable
higher capacities we've been capped at
two terabytes for a while some people
even have two plans so maybe they'll go
up to five and give a larger amount for
people to use especially with family
plans which is the way that i use it now
with that a lot of people and
publications have been talking about how
this is the missing piece from apple's
lineup people are saying they should
bring it back it makes sense especially
now with these brand new m1 and upcoming
m2 powered macs so apple it seems like
is going to give people what they want
now you guys let me know down below is
this something that you're interested in
will you buy something from apple that
can be integrated in the whole ecosystem
or do you already have another solution
that works really well for you i want to
hear your thoughts down below go ahead
and click that circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]